japan bleibt auf jeden fall bis zum ende
dran weil dann könnt ihr doch was
gewinnen so etwas klappt herzlich
willkommen beim ein video ich hoffe ich
bin noch scharf und bin ich eigentlich
immer etwas glaubt herzlich willkommen
beim ein video und zwar habt ihr es
wahrscheinlich am titel schon gelesen
auf jeden fall habe ich letzte woche mit
meinem bruder eine versuche nicht zu
lachen challenge gemacht und wir
überlegen jetzt mal was wir denn so als
bestrafung machen können beziehungsweise
ich muss erst mal gucken wer verloren
hat
und das machen wir es einfach mal sofort
berlin berlin komme ich hab so voll das
schlechte gefühl weil ich glaube ich
habe verloren weil ich hab das noch mal
nachgeguckt aber wird haben wir denn
hier alex hat mehr gelacht 166 leichtfuß
leute was heute dein alter nicht mehr
gelacht
seit monaten mehr gelacht 72 kubin
meisten gemacht ganz klar alexander
gebracht hat mir gedacht habe allerdings
hat mehr gemacht so leute ich würd sagen
wir warten einfach mal kurz bisher
kommt was glaubst du wert verloren was
willst du gucken also ich würde sagen du
als verloren mit abstand nicht doch
nicht mal welche alex hat mehr gelacht
standard dann würde ich mal sagen du
darfst jetzt was für mich überlegen
beide ich die kamera ist leer
dann musst du dieses wiki hat sie schon
etwas überlegt ja weißt du wusstest du
dass ich verloren
ja ich hatte selber schon was machen
dieses pipi machen es nicht so vorlaut
wie mein zeuge ich muss machen
diese die sachen so was halt in kaufen
dann ausnahme ich gebe jetzt sich für
ein video so viel geld aus für die
ganzen sagt hat er seine hose wieso hat
dass so viele klicks okay leute passt
auf ich fahre morgen nach köln bis
donnerstag und ich würde sagen dann
macht das einfach da passt auch das wird
heftig bis später
was geht ab leute ich weiß ich sehe aus
als hätte ich gar nicht geschlafen aber
ich habe ein bisschen geschlafen wir
haben auf jeden fall gestern für mein
neues musikvideo gedreht es kommt bald
online könnt ihr euch auf jeden fall
drauf freuen ich bin sehr zufrieden
damit mehr will ich dazu ist doch gar
nicht sagen auf jeden fall
ich bin in köln bin voll am arsch aber
wir gehen jetzt in die stadt ich hatte
mir gerade hier diesen typen angeguckt
ich muss ja ein bisschen wissen wie es
funktioniert und wieder aussieht und wir
suchen jetzt einfach mal nach einem
passenden outfit für mich in irgendeinem
shop ihr und dann versuche ich das ganz
einfach mal so gut wie möglich
umzusetzen auch wenn es fertig ist aber
ich muss das machen ich weiß also bis
gleich on the street
wie ich gar nicht geschlafen la la la la
la la la la la
ich bin immer noch nicht da
leute ich hab jetzt hier eingekauft das
outfit ist echt heftig ich weiß nicht ob
es ihr passt aber ist ja auch eigentlich
scheißegal es wird mir schon passen
jeden fall noch ein paar andere ja soll
ich sagen ihr werdet es gleich sehen ich
will gar nicht eingeladen bis gleich wie
schon gesagt und zwar hier ein geiles
hemd tatsächlich aber gleich genauer und
kanal wo das herkommt manche auch nicht
und eine sonnenbrille
die sec fresh und ja meine hose habe ich
leider vergessen
aber ich wette es wird trotzdem krass
und ich würde sagen wir fangen direkt
baden viel schwarz das noch nach oben da
jetzt schon ab apple hp laptop
ach du scheiße das ist irgendwie so ging
das glaube ich möchte wer was ja heute
scheißegal ich hoffe dieses jeder hat
euch ein bisschen unterhalten so und wir
hatten spaß und ich habe mir gedacht ich
brauche das nicht mehr weil die scheiße
aus ich verlasse das einfach abschreibt
du einfach ein kommentar wie zum
beispiel alex das war schlecht oder alex
du bist cool oder irgendwie sowas und
den automatisch an der verlosung teil
und ihr könnt gerne daumen nach oben da
lassen
das erhöhte gewinnchance audi nicht
vergessen und sondern scheiße mache ich
echt nicht wieder